[Music]
foreign
and here are your daughters Angela and
Catherine about seven hours ago and
that's the last information we have
Catherine hey hey you found her
me and Catherine are doing all day in
those woods you're just walking and
walking
Angela can you tell your dad how long
you were gone a few hours
maybe you've been gone three days
yeah
[Music]
what'd you say I didn't say nothing
sorry I heard you say something
hey baby
you okay
wherever those girls went through
brought something back with them the
body of Love of Jesus Christ
foreign
body in the blood
the body in the blood the body and the
blood
[Applause]
have you ever seen anything like this
on me no but there are people out there
who have
[Music]
[Applause]
yes more than I'd like
I believe you can help get our girls
back
exorcism is a ritual
culture every religion they all use
different methods it's going to take all
of them
[Music]
we've met before
[Applause]
[Music]
what did you do
foreign
[Music]
thank you